[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's take a look at all the
Transformers that were seen in the rise
of the Beast trailer which will include
the Autobots the maximals the terracons
and in the end we will tell you about
the Decepticon which was surprisingly
built by humans in the 90s let's get to
it
number one Optimus Prime of course the
leader of the Autobots need no
introduction and he was seen in the
trailer in the G1 version or design as
all of them are which by the way is a
sequel to Bumblebee and in turn which
was a soft reboot to the Transformers
live action timeline so Prime is seen in
all his red and blue Plus Chrome Glory
transforming into a 1987 Freightliner
truck number 2 Bumblebee the heart and
soul of the Autobots and a fan favorite
will also return in this movie and he
will have lost his voice by this time
lost in the battle with blitzwing in the
previous movie Bumblebee the yellow
robot will have also gone past his
Volkswagen Beetle days and will be
transforming into an older version of
the Chevrolet Camaro
number three RC RC was a field commander
for the Autobots although she was never
the hardest or the biggest of the
Autobots she was still a tough addition
to the team as she was small agile and
carried quite a punch she's usually
transformed into a sports bike more
specifically a Ducati Superbike
number four Mirage he is an Autobot who
possessed a wide range of infiltration
skills and was originally seen to
transform into a red Ferrari but in the
rise of the Beast Mirage will be
morphing into a silver Porsche 964 with
a blue stripe down the middle he is the
more talkative version of Bumblebee
number five wheel Jack although seen as
a smaller robot Einstein in the Beavers
movies in Rise of the beast real Jack
would be a larger Transformer and still
one of the leading scientists of the
Autobots he was seen slightly in a
trailer walking with the other Autobots
including Prime and Aussie
number six Optimus primal this
Transformer with the eerily similar name
to Prime is the commander of the
maximals and a captain of the Starship
axelon the spaceship would have landed
on Earth millions of years in the past
and he alongside the other maximals will
be living in hiding for a long time
transforming to look like animals on the
planet he himself transforms into a
gorilla in his Beast face
number seven rhinops he is the brute
strength of the maximals and takes the
form of a rhino his double and triple
steel plated skin Shields him from most
injury including durability against
double barrel laser guns in previous
encounters and battles in the past he
has even fought Megatron to a standstill
without breaking a sweat
number 8 Cheeto he is one of the
maximals who transforms into a large
cheetah he is an efficient killing
machine striking hard and fast with
Incredible reflexes in both beast mode
or robot mode he was well known to
openly dare Predacons to challenge him
and his laser-powered Quasar cannons
number nine air razor because of her
Airborne alternative form that takes the
form of a gigantic Eagle air razor
serves as the Maximus Recon surveillance
member she is calm and confident but
also daring and adventurous her ability
to fly as well as her acute eyesight and
steady shot makes her a Powerhouse
number 10 Scourge one of the deadliest
of the Decepticons and a subordinate to
only Megatron in the cybertronian Army
Scourge is the main villain of the
upcoming flake Scourge is an impeccable
tracker and a leader of the deadly
sweeps he was said to be created by
Unicron himself from the remains of
another dead Decepticon so now he is a
Terracon now this transform is out to
control the terracons on Earth
number 11 battle trap battle trap is one
of the film's villains and was
previously a member of scorpionov's army
of Decepticons and Cybertron battle trap
morphs into a yellow orange GMC tow
truck in vehicle mode he is in fact a
Decepticon neither a Terracon or a
Predacon he would be playing a big role
in the rise of the Beast movie as one of
the subordinates of scourge
number 12 the terracons this rageful
almost mindless terracons created from
the dead Transformers imbued with dark
Energon other decepticon's most valuable
asset an undead Army underscourages
control each is forceful and unyielding
in his own right they are the thin metal
skeleton-like Transformers shown in the
trailer in large numbers
and number 13 night bird night bird was
a robotic ninja fighter built by Dr
Fujiyama presumably to demonstrate how
sophisticated human technology had
gotten the Decepticons then kidnapped
night bird and implanted her with an
upgraded brain chip transforming this
drone-like night bird into a genuine
butt kicking machine for the Decepticons
as to what or if she is able to
transform is yet to be determined
so I hope you have enjoyed watching this
video on the 13 Transformers scene in
the rise of the Beast trailer hit that
like button for support subscribe and
that Bell icon for regular updates on
new videos here on this channel till the
next one take care fam